hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
will heute gibt es wieder ein rezept aus
meiner kategorie sallys classics und
zwar werde ich heute einen bienenstich
machen denn hatten sich ganz viele von
euch gewünscht und ich werde euch jetzt
gleich zeigen was er natürlich an
zutaten braucht aber wie ihr seht stehe
ich jetzt immer noch in meiner alten
küche und der raum der halt irgendwie so
sehr weil bei uns einfach gar nichts
mehr in der wohnung drin steht außer
mein und torten dummies hier an der
seite wissen wirklich komplett
ausgezogen nur die küche bleibt hier
und deswegen habe ich das jetzt eben
genutzt um dieses video noch hier zu
drehen
wir müssen nämlich ewig lange auf unsere
möbel warten und sie jetzt in die neue
wohnung die noch nicht fertig ist und ja
haben ganz viel ausgemistet und der ein
oder andere kennt das bestimmt
vielleicht steckt ihr gerade auch mitten
im umzug und das ist schon ziemlich
stressig und nervenaufreibend aber es
wird ihr dann immer irgendwie etwas
schöner
ich habe jetzt den bienenstich für euch
vorbereitet und zwar mag dass mein mann
auch ganz gerne das rezept und da gibt's
ja ganz viele verschiedene alternativen
aber ich möchte ich heute einfach mal so
dieses traditionelle rezept zeigen und
werde irgendwann anders mal richtung
sommer ein etwas frischeres rezept
zeigen wo eben dort auch etwas leichter
wird
ich werde jetzt nämlich den teig aus
hefeteig herstellen und zeigt mich da
einmal die zutaten für den hefeteig
braucht ihr 250 gramm mehl einen halben
würfel hefe 125 milliliter lauwarme
milch 40 gramm zucker ein kleines ei ein
viertel teelöffel salz und 40 gramm
butter die habe ich jetzt etwas in der
mikrobe letzter lassen
zuerst gebe ich jetzt das mehl in eine
schüssel ihr könnt das ganze natürlich
auch mit hand verkneten ich mach das
heute allerdings mit der küchenmaschine
da mache ich da eine kleine mulde rein
stellt ganz kurz zur seite
und neben mir die lauwarme milch und
brösel dort jetzt meine hefe hinein
ihr könnt natürlich auch mit trockenhefe
machen
allerdings finde ich dass der hefeteig
mit frischhefe viel besser wird
da werde ich das kurz verrühren
damit sich die hefe auflöst diese hefe
und milch mischung gebe ich jetzt hier
ins mehl mit dazu einfach in diese
vertiefen
da kommt jetzt noch da zucker mit dazu
das wird ganz kurz verrührt und ich
werde es jetzt heute wieder mit der
warmen führe machen also mit dem vorteig
ihr könnt es natürlich auch weglassen
und jetzt einfach alles anderen zutaten
mit dazugeben und verkneten ich bedeckt
es ist allerdings noch mit dem
restlichen mail verschließe den deckel
und lass es so jetzt an einem warmen ort
super etwa 30 grad im ofen für etwa zehn
minuten stehen bis einfach die hefe
etwas aufgeht und dann geht es gleich
weiter
die hierfür dürfte jetzt ein wenig
aufgehen und jetzt gebe ich einfach die
restlichen zutaten mit rein also dass
das salz und jetzt auch die butter denn
die hefe ist jetzt schon mit der milch
vermengt deswegen darf jetzt auch die
butter mit dazu wenn ihr das ganze ohne
vorteil macht dann gebt ihr die butter
trotzdem erst zum schluss mit dazu und
last vorhält und kind etwas verkneten
den teig lasse ich jetzt in meiner küche
maschine verkneten bis er richtig schön
elastisch ist also das wird bei mir zu
etwa fünf minuten dauern
wenn die den mit der hand verknetet
dürfte es ruhig etwas länger machen
und wenn ihr merkt dass das zu klebrig
es gibt einfach ein ganz kleines
bisschen mehl mit dazu sieht jetzt bei
mir der fertige teig aus da es immer
noch ziemlich weich aber ihr seht als
nicht klebrig und so soll es auch sein
wie guy klangeffekte kein chart
jetzt gebe ich einfach etwas mehl auf
eine arbeitsfläche einfach so ein
bisschen das war der kopf und hat den
teig jetzt hier schön daraus die hände
waschen und jetzt freue mich den teig
einfach zu einer ganz kleinen kugel
zusammen mit etwas mehl in eine schüssel
und legt im teig hinein und da darf
jetzt wieder an einem warmen ort also
bei mir im ofen bei maximal 30 grad
etwas aufgeben mein tag ist jetzt
aufgegangen und jetzt nehme ich ihn aus
der form heraus ich sehe das geht ganz
einfach und ich arbeite heute auch mit
einfachen mitteln weil ich meine ganze
küche schon eingepackt habe für den
umzug und habe jetzt nicht mehr alles
werkzeug da was ich brauche
aber das geht auch alles ohne jetzt wenn
ich das einfach ein bisschen mit den
händen flach drücken
normalerweise würde ich das jetzt mit
dem ausruf staat machen und habe mir
meine form zurechtgelegt und zwar mag
ich das heute mit meinem backblech meine
dauer werk folie und den bug rahmen und
jetzt breit ich hier den teig schön aus
und meinen brand habe ich jetzt auf die
größe von 26 cm eingestellt das ist bei
diesem bug rahmen wirklich super denn
ich kann das hier einstellen
und hier am rand erkennt man das dann
dann weiß ich jetzt ganz genau jetzt
habe ich die 26 cm und das passt perfekt
und wenn ihr den bienenstich nicht rund
machen wollt könnt ihr auch eckig machen
und da würde ich die form auf 25 cm
einstellen als 25 25 so las ich den teig
jetzt noch einmal aufgehen und wird in
dieser zeit den belag vorbereiten
ihr braucht 100 gramm butter 100 g
zucker einen esslöffel sahne und 130
gramm mandeln und zwar habe ich hier
einmal gehobelte mandeln 65 gramm und 65
gramm gestiftete mandeln weil ich ganz
gerne habe dass diese gestiftete mandeln
ebenso knusprig werden und zur cross und
ihr könnt natürlich auch nur gehobelte
mandeln oder eben nur gestiftete mandeln
aber ich finde einfach die kombination
richtig super
wenn das ganze dann schön koch könnt ihr
die mantel mit dazu geben
immer schön früher das müsste aufpassen
dass es euch nicht anbrennt sind es soll
sich jetzt ja nur schön vermischen und
karamellisieren darf dann im ofen jetzt
schalte ich meinen hut aus und der belag
ist bereit
ich sehe mein tag ist noch mal richtig
schön aufgegangen und jetzt kommt direkt
der belag drauf und zwar so dass er eben
noch warm ist
denn nur wenn der belag war mist ist ja
auch schön streichfähig es gebe ich das
hier mal so ganz unregelmäßig darauf
nicht auf eine stelle weil sonst wird
diese eine stelle eingedrückt und dann
wird der teig nicht mehr gleichmäßig
erstmal so verteilen
und jetzt wird es hier auch schön
verteilt
da müsste jetzt aufpassen weil das ganze
sehr heiß ist und ihr seht der schwere
belag drückt jetzt noch mal ein bisschen
runter
das macht jetzt aber nix ich werde ihn
dann nämlich einfach noch mal kurz gehen
lassen und während mein ofen jetzt auf
190 grad vor ober und unterhitze vor
heizt lasse ich den jetzt einfach kurz
hier stehen dafür kurz weiter gehen und
dann geht er in den ofen
mein tag ist jetzt aufgegangen und jetzt
werde ich ihnen bei 190 grad ober und
unterhitze für etwa 30 minuten backen
ist hier dass der teig nicht ganz
gleichmäßig bedeckt ist es macht aber
nicht es ist auch es extrem schwierig
den ganz gleichmäßig zu bedecken
aber das sieht so wirklich schon
wunderschön aus und wenn er dann eine
goldbraune kruste hat werde ich ihn aus
dem ofen nehmen
so sieht jetzt mein kuchen fertig
gebacken aus ich habe jetzt keine
stäbchen probe gemacht weil ich meine
ansprache auch schon weggepackt habe
aber allein schon von der farbe dürfte
sind so passen
ich habe auch schon unten reingeguckt da
ist die farbe genauso schön goldbraun
jetzt denke ich den kuchen einfach ab
und schloss ihn aus kühler
so sieht man kuchen jetzt aus der ist
vollständig abgekühlt und jetzt kann ich
den torten rand entfernen und zwar
müssen jetzt aufpassen dass sie die
folie nicht zerschneidet und können
jetzt eigentlich auch wieder diesen
dieses torten rand messer benutzen
das habe ich jetzt nur leider nicht da
weil wir schon
alles weg gepackt haben deswegen meine
tortenplatte und jetzt fahre ich da mit
einem ganz normalen spitzen messer am
rand entlang und jetzt werde ich den
kuchen einmal waagerecht halbieren und
nehme dazu ein scharfes torten messer
setzt es hier am rand an und es geht
natürlich am besten wenn ihr das auf
einer drehbaren platte macht und kann da
einmal durch
jetzt habe ich das kurz hoch legt eine
tortenplatte hinauf durch das servieren
möchte
und lass es jetzt darauf bleiben und
kann jetzt mit dem torten retter den
deckel abnehmen und ich sehe jetzt auch
richtig schön diese feinen poren und den
boden weil ich jetzt mit ihm trocken
ring umschließen
dann nehme ich einfach meinen hohen
tortenring oder ihr nehmt einfach den
gleichen anbieter und reinigt den eben
und damit sich der kuchen später
einfacher schneiden lässt weil ich jetzt
diesen deckel schon mal zerschneiden und
zwar habe ich jetzt hier so einen kuchen
einteiler
den braucht man nicht unbedingt aber
wenn man ihn hat ist es natürlich
hervorragend weil ich dann meinen kuchen
einfach einteilen kann indem ich das
einfach etwas an drücke ihr könnt es
jetzt wahrscheinlich durch die kamera
nicht ganz gut erkennen und dann kann
ich den kuchen so zu teilen wie ich eben
hier angedeutet habe
und wenn ihr die obere platte jetzt auch
zerteilt habt könnt ihr die zur seite
stellen
und jetzt mache ich die kriegen fertig
und setzte dann die torte zusammen beim
bienenstich ist es so dass es so sein
muss dass mindestens 20 das gewicht also
das trockengewicht der belag sein muss
also dieser mantel decke und deswegen
ist als eben auch so viel drauf ihr
könnt aber natürlich auch etwas mehr
oder etwas weniger benutzen
wobei ich diese portion jetzt wirklich
perfekt finde weil wenn man mehr nimmt
hat man als süße schicht wenn man
weniger nimmt hat man zu wenig meint
mandelblättchen und ich finde so richtig
perfekt ich habe jetzt ein paar
füllungen für euch und zwar gibt es
diese traditionelle füllung die deutsche
buttercreme die aus pudding und butter
hergestellt wird die werde ich euch
heute ich jetzt nicht zeigen weil ich
die zeigen möchte wenn ich demnächst die
donauwelle backe da finde ich sie
nämlich richtig lecker ihr könnt den
bienenstich jetzt zum beispiel aber auch
einfach mit sahne firmen da würde ich
jetzt einfach 300 gramm sahne nehmen und
die eben steif schlagen
etwas schneller thiele oder akazie
unterziehen und dann eben die torte
befüllung oder ihr macht einen pudding
mit etwas milch und stärke
da werde ich euch das genaue rezept auf
meinem blog verlinken und zwar stellt
man da aus pudding und stärke einen ganz
normalen pudding her und zieht dann
etwas steif geschlagene sahne unter das
ist dann so eine etwas leichtere creme
da muss man allerdings auch etwas
schnell ermittelte zu benutzen also
entweder gelatine oder akne und ich
werde euch jetzt heute noch als dritte
variante oder besser gesagt als vierte
variante eine creme zeigen und zwar
werde ich diese creme aus butter und
sahne park machen weil ich da noch etwas
milch benutzen kann das heißt ich hab
dann eigentlich nur so ein stück butter
und der rest wird dann eben nicht in
pudding oder irgendetwas anderes sondern
das geht aus milch und sahne park
gemacht und es zeige ich hätte einfach
jetzt und ihr könnt dann eben selbst
entscheiden ob ihr die ganz normale
sahne nehmt ob ihr die pudding
buttercreme nimmt ob ihr die mutter mit
sahne nehmt oder eben die die ich euch
jetzt zeigen
für die füllung braucht ihr 250 gramm
zimmer warme butter 400 milliliter milch
und einen beutel salat und zwar ist das
pflanzlich und ohne gelatine da ist
einfach nur etwas zucker drin mit etwas
stärke und mehl und daraus werde ich
jetzt diese creme machen die mädels hab
ich jetzt bereits in einer schüssel
gegeben und werde da jetzt das typische
sein apartment einrühren und das ganze
schön glatt verrühren
das muss jetzt auch gar nicht steif
geschlagen werden sondern soll nur kurz
klümpchen freigeräumt werden
und jetzt werde ich in meiner zweiten
schüssel die butter schön weich rühren
und schön cremig und wenn das ganze dann
schön cremig gerührt ist gebt ihr jetzt
löffelweise diese st anna park misch und
mit dazu
und hier sieht man auch bisschen dass
sie schon beginnt zu gelieren und das
gebe ich jetzt während dem rühren ganz
vorsichtig mit dazu
die fertige creme hat hier eine richtig
feste konsistenz und die werde ich jetzt
hier auf dem tortenboden verteidigen
jetzt nehme ich mir meine einzelnen
tortenstücke und setz dich schön oben
drauf
meine torte war jetzt im kühlschrank und
jetzt werde ich euch zeigen mich den
tortenring entferne ich werde den
tortenring nicht hochziehen weil ich
nicht möchte dass dann die sahne mit
hoch kommt sondern ich werde ihn jetzt
einfach öffnen
das ist nämlich auch der vorteil von dem
tortenring und wenn ihr dann seht ihr
braucht doch etwas unterstützung neben
deutsch einfach ein kleines messer oder
eine palette und könnte sitzt hier noch
etwas ganz streichen
jetzt auch ich habe ihn jetzt nicht so
hoch ich hab jetzt nicht zu viel creme
drin denn ich finde wenn man da zu viel
creme reimer schmeckt er kuchen auch
viel so mächtig und dann könnt ihr den
bienenstich einfach schön zerschneiden
weil die obere schicht ist ja schon
durch jetzt nicht einfach noch die
untere schicht schneiden
ich mache mein messer ist immer wieder
mit etwas zäh war sauber nach vorne
damit ich jetzt nicht mit der sahne hier
an die oberfläche kommen und es hässlich
aussieht
das messer ist jetzt ein bisschen
ungeeignet aber ich habe kein anderes es
ist nicht schlimm wenn da auch ab und zu
mal so ein paar mantel später runter
fallen die können nämlich ganz einfach
verlassen wollte ich ein quad vernaschen
und mein mann hat gesagt so was erleben
jetzt einmal keine gabel keine messer
und haben aber den schönen bienenstich
stehen
das heißt ich zeig ich dir jetzt einfach
mal so
so sieht jetzt mein fertiger bienenstich
aus anderen weise eine gallone
ich habe jetzt einfach einen weißen ich
liebe bienenstich ich liebe diese man
wusste aber ich werde euch mal eine
variante zeigen mit etwas frucht füllung
mit drin als auch so ein bisschen
auflockernde erfrischende frucht füllung
entschuldigung ich hab ich ganz
ignoriert ich kann mir nämlich auch
super mit apfel vorstellen oder auch mit
sommerlichen früchten mit etwas weniger
butter mit einer quark für lungen- oder
sahne füllung als so richtig schön
locker
denn solches war ein traditioneller
klassischer bienenstich aber ich finde
im sommer muss das ein bisschen lockerer
werden also so ein bisschen aufgefrischt
und aufgepeppt dieses rezept gibt es
natürlich zum nachlesen auf www.cewe.de
da werde ich euch natürlich diese
variante zeigen aber auch die anderen
varianten also diese creme füllungen
eben da einfach einschreiben und ihr
entscheidet euch für die eine oder die
andere und wir werden jetzt den kuchen
genießen ich muss jetzt noch gucken dass
ich irgendwie foto für euch schießen
kann für instagram da dürfte wäre ich
auch da dürfte nämlich auch kinder
folgen
und da heißt york citys torten welt auf
facebook könnt ihr erfolgen und mehr
gerne schreiben da freue ich mich immer
trüber und das nächste mal sehen wir uns
hoffentlich in der neuen wohnung leider
ohne küche da schaue ich dann mal wo ich
meine videos machen und ich freue mich
schon bis dahin
was mache ich
doch mit dem schwäbischen eine ganze
woche schwäbisch gucken